[Music]
let's
start it off with blake in wichita
kansas blake how can we help
hey so i started on the you know the
whole baby steps and everything
uh around august of last year and i had
um you know started paying things down
and what not because i know randy's
thing is you got to get current before
you can
you know start the snowball from my
understanding
but i had surgery in november and then i
was out till february and then i got
laid off in april
and then was laid off and didn't have a
job for a couple months and so we fell
behind on things again
and so i'm just trying to figure out
what i need to do
to get back on track like or to the
point now that
we're almost caught back up but i just
i'm kind of
i'm stuck in a pickle you're rotating
your language a little bit you said i
you said i then you said we
so who's who's i and we okay i'm sorry
uh
my my fiance and i your fiance okay so
are you all working together on this
plan do you each are you all sharing
plans or
how are y'all managing this together
yeah
uh we've we've sat down quite a few
times and like worked out the budget and
everything um she's currently a
stay-at-home mom we have uh
two boys and so obviously that
hinders how fast things can be
accomplished what do you mean
what do you mean specifically when you
say we've got to get caught up first
before we work the baby steps i'm i'm a
little fuzzy on what you mean
uh so because i had gotten laid off um
we had
fallen behind on uh like utilities and
rent and things like that
okay i got it so did you just not pay
did you have to get a credit card out
did you just go into a
are you 90 days behind your bills where
are you
um uh as of now because i have started
working again so i've been working for
about three months now
again and we're caught up on everything
except for our water and it's only
a month or two months behind now okay
and so
are you guys living beans and rice are
y'all cutting out all the nonsense to
get caught up on this because these
aren't frivolous things these are four
walls things these are basic necessities
brother you got to have water
just want to make sure that you're
getting the gravity of this one
yeah yeah no we've we've cut out all the
extra spending and everything like that
already
very cool so what's your what's your big
question sounds like you guys hit a hit
a pothole
you're got a job you're kicking butt
you're getting back on it
are you just getting frustrated and worn
out and exhausted
i i guess my biggest question is and
where i don't know what to do
is um we had bought a
20 20 uh chevy trax
because we had paid off our other
vehicle with the tax return so we had
one vehicle that didn't have anything
right our other vehicle had a bunch of
problems and so we traded it in and
ended up carrying money over to the
tracks and so that's a
thirty thousand dollar loan um which is
more than what the vehicle is worth so
the biggest question is to get us
started is do we sell it for what we can
get out of it
which is roughly twenty thousand just
make map easy
and then have just a ten thousand dollar
loan to make payments on and buy
two cheaper vehicles or a at per vehicle
because i actually already have one
that's
completely paid off well before we get
to that
okay how how long before you're going to
get caught up on the water bill
um hopefully october 9th
it should be completely caught up and
you both are working now
no just you yes and she
and she's got the little guys a little
the little folks at home so she's got to
take care of the kiddos
yeah how long has she been your fiance
uh we've been engaged for about a year
and a half now what are we waiting on
um money yeah
okay so so so is it possible do you have
friends and family
in the in your area that might be able
to you know step up for the
short term and watch the children for
her to work at least
20 hours a week is that even an option
have you looked at that
um she also so she starts school again
in not
on october 19. so
how is she paying for school she
has student loans okay what is she going
to school for
nursing okay so who's watching the kids
while she's going to school
uh her mother okay um
how much does she have left in the
nursing degree or the program how much
time
just a year okay um
and okay john here's the deal i'm
working to here's the deal
this week we can't over complicate this
um
you're only working one job is that
right
yes you need another job because what
you have got to do
is we've got to get current and we've
got to get not just current but we've
got to get enough
income coming in for you to not just get
current on the water but to very
quickly get that baby step one taken
care of which is a thousand dollars
just to cover your garden variety
emergency do you understand what i'm
saying
all right and then everything else is
attacking that debt
and then yes once you get baby step
uh one taken care of we start taking the
smallest debts
and we attack them what else besides the
thirty thousand dollar
van or whatever it is do you have
um it's mostly the rest of it's all
school loans between her and i
okay she's got roughly 50 because she
was at ku
and that was before i we had got
together and then i think i have
uh 18 000 in total okay
so blake i want to take a step back even
further than what can
can ken's well hold on before we get i'm
going to be very quick so here's the
deal blake
so what you need to do is is you do the
1 000.
you need a second job maybe even a third
job you got family there to help with
the kids this is all in man
going absolutely bananas gazelle intense
thousand dollars in mercy fun and then
uh what i want you to do is yes i would
sell that car
and and so now you create a ten thousand
dollar loan in 18 and a 50 and you
attack the 10.
so yes that's what i want you to do john
go ahead blake i want you to see what
happened for what it was
okay you hit an ice patch and you almost
went completely over the side
to the point that you have two little
kids a fiance
you're completely untethered trying to
hold 50 different plates spinning at
once
and you guys almost went over the edge
you were about another 30 days from
going over the edge weren't you
right i want you to recognize this for
the cosmic gift that it was
you're living a a plan free life
a vision free life and i understand what
it's like to all of a sudden you wake up
you got two kids things are spinning
you and your fiance have to get off the
track for a second
and come up with a plan together it's
gonna 100 include what ken's talking
about
but you cannot live untethered anymore
brother it's gonna
push you over the edge you're one more
mistake from letting it happen
three jobs get on a plan start cracking
down
get married get it right yeah and no
more death no more ever
and put a ring on it my goodness